there you are you're your brain you're
locked inside this bony sculpt it's dark
in there it's silent all you've got to
go on as a brain are streams of
electrical signals which are only
indirectly related to things in the
world whatever they may be and from
these noisy ambiguous electrical signals
the brain conjures forth a world full of
things with positions and properties how
does it do that the idea and this is an
idea that goes way back in science and
in philosophy is that it's a process of
inference of some kind brain is
continually generating predictions about
the causes of its sensory signals
sensory data that comes in is just
calibrating these predictions it's
updating them what you perceive that is
the hypothesis is the contents of the
brain's predictions not a readout of the
sensory data